I was like surprised but not shocked
honestly I feel like there was like a
little voice inside that was like girl
you're going up for sure well do you
think that you could have one if not for
the twist or did you feel like this was
becoming inevitable I think whenever
there was gonna be a backdoor option it
was gonna be used on either myself or
Johnny probably me first I would have
said because I knew as soon as I hit
that block I was probably going home
was there ever anyone you thought that
Kalyan might target instead I thought
that maybe she'd target Allie and live
as the other duo but she also I think
was thinking of them as more of a shield
and using them as a way to move forward
so I figured that if not Johnny or
myself I don't really know where her
target would've landed turn off you
tries to take the target off yourself
last week by taking Merrin out in
hindsight do you think that that worked
or do you wish that you had stuck to
your guns and been this big player that
you tried to be I think I think it might
have been less of trying to minimize my
target because I knew my target wasn't
getting any smaller but I just wanted to
play a little more long-term and I was
like okay let's slow it down
and kind of take a breath because after
having two back-to-back HOH weeks I was
exhausted honestly I was really really
mentally drained but now in hindsight
100% I wish I just took the shot
especially with Johnny winning the veto
after putting those noms up great
opportunity to pull Ryan down put Kayla
up and then who knows I'd probably still
be in there but then again there's so
many moving parts it's impossible to
like predict what's gonna happen I could
have never anticipated a twist like this
so no regrets no regrets you know
amazing well I was gonna do you have any
regrets in the games like ice no right
no honestly I'm really proud of the game
that I played and besides winning of
course all I wanted from this game at
any point of being evicted was to be
able to look back and know that I played
the best game I possibly knew how and I
think I did that and I hope it comes
across I hope I'm proud now watching it
back I don't have to see maybe this
interview will be a little different
once I watch it and I'm like okay way
this is so cringeworthy never mind but
no I am proud so at the moment now who
do you think was your number one
in the house I think well Hamza before
he got evicted but once he was evicted
Johnny for sure and maybe I will also
regret that watching him back and
realize like Johnny was against me the
whole time but I mean I I felt more
trust in Johnny than I did in a lot of
other people in that house for sure what
do you think was the most surprising and
or memorable part of being part of big
really Canada I think the entire
experience of course is incredibly
memorable I'm never gonna forget this
but I think for me it's just surmounting
all of the limitations that I put on
myself before coming in like I believe
it or not I never thought that I was a
comp beast kind of player at all I was
like okay I can go in there be social I
think people will gravitate towards me
but comps I was like okay I'm screwed
for comms and to see that I could pull
through and actually like for calm winds
in six weeks is pretty impressive so I
think just I don't know I think doing
things that I never first saw myself
being able to do is gonna be the most
memorable part